hey guys welcome to another episode of
Rishta fury I'm Kelsey cook and today I
am joined by two of the most requested
guests so far actually of the show
always stare at the elbow of the about
last night podcast you also know Brad
from multiple showtime specials you know
Adam from MADtv the movie the heat
Ghostbusters I mean yeah and now and now
I have a lot of free time now that a
game of Thrones is over obviously I'm
not doing that anymore
right thank you so much yes yeah we had
to wait hose over to get you on them
yeah I just have a boatload of money now
I just have so much money like I I just
decided to come and play foosball first
it's like charity work webseries it's
pretty low I appreciate it so I'm so
excited play you guys you guys have any
foosball experience what do I have
coming into this today well see as a as
a person who is the size of many of the
players on the field right guys got a
sag card by being yeah the red guy's the
middle red guy yep like you wanna know
that in quite show do the show your
audition again got the role from World
Cup 96 nailed it every foosball movie
I'm one of the guys and they actually
you auditioned originally for the black
guy but show them what you did for that
and why you didn't get it out and they
were like this yeah typical it's true
but a stereotypical
yeah you're gonna be the right guy yeah
exactly wait have you made like against
a professional before I've never played
against a professional I used to play
foosball or as a kid my friend Ryan had
to take it and that that's why I went to
the defensive side because that was your
wheelhouse
yes I was a defenseman at hockey III I
know about that kind of thing I'm about
to say that while I'm about to be
destroyed no it's warm enough I'm
impressed
and I was really excited by doing the
show because for those of your viewers
that sauce on something's burning I felt
I I fell into something's burning -
school I wish the stool for the rest of
it jumping out of a tree house yeah as a
purist of the game I don't feel I should
be using a stool because I feel like
that's kind of it's kind of like the
episode of Seinfeld where the dwarves
were lifting I just don't I just don't
think that's pure and I mean it for the
integrity of the game how it works when
you're playing doubles so on your guys's
side you can switch at the end of every
point I think we should do something
completely outrageous we're like yeah I
think we should do it this way and
that's that's never been done before so
you don't even know what to expect
yes even crazier a little Titanic
situation king of the world well that we
could yeah that that comes if we win
yeah yeah beautiful
this one doesn't move is that supposed
to yeah sorry rigged Wow I see why
you've been beating everybody
Riggs said court advantage you know yeah
is this a penis pump what is this that's
he walks out holding a pump but he's
like I hope with his penis pump on me
that's not mine
I was hoping Tony Danza would come out
at some point but I just feel like
without you what is this a penis pump I
tried to get that in season four he's
the boss but uh you know Jonathan had a
problem with it marinas do standard game
two five has anyone ever been skunked
before on the show pretty much every
episode no way yeah so people don't
score at all not usually the first game
during the second game I will play the
whole game blindfolded or whole game
hand captures going by feel okay you
ready
yes okay go for it we have no music huh
we just played dry
[Music]
okay someone is a dead spot between
those two men it goes back to me I swear
I'm not cheating that's right okay okay
ready
oh that's what we call it oh damn it
God really decent shot I'm working with
tiny men what what was that was that
like 45 seconds I mean that's part we
didn't get to a minute dude okay my
stepmom after that one I like what
Kelsey's doing so Steph Curry like
dancing outside the three-point line
yeah still your shot because you keep
losing so then you keep getting the ball
do you know Brad we are going for ice
cream after this okay what is that nope
[ __ ] you think that's the first time
oh my god that's weird like Kenny so
we're tough and then it goes right into
my guy okay you should go take a pee
break like that's our only chance to win
out if she's gone sorry Brad I got this
[Applause]
save read okay so I don't want to like
distract you Brad about to play defense
but you were talking about playing laser
tag this is the epic comeback we're fine
yeah this is this is what we do so Brad
you were saying that you you're like
weird hobby the way I play foosball is
that you are like a pro laser tag play
yeah
really good at laser - how did this come
about I run and I hide really well damn
it
one thing I don't do is defense all
right well hey you know what let's get
up really it's one ball why not have you
[Laughter]
get for cheating [ __ ] so all
right so that's that's one okay so
that's game one what do we play two five
oh yeah be thankful that we were only
playing to five yeah what happens kind
of cranky but also like I also am
realistic as far as like what I but you
know that's also the due to me being
like this is definitely putting that to
rest because this is you're also so good
thanks
we're gonna do a second game where we
gonna we're gonna introduce some like
penalties and okay it's to make it
easier so come over here we're gonna
we're gonna do this little fun okay so
you want pick one oh sure that one okay
which is a four what does that mean okay
I'm three so your guys's penalty I kind
of said it before but you guys have to
play crisscross like twister style with
each other so like if you've got one
hand here Adam you do this and vice
versa so it's like what you said before
maybe that will give you an advantage I
don't know so what that means like I'm
goalie in this guy yeah or these two so
next week we're playing horrible and now
we're just trying to devise a way for us
to be even worse yeah but I have to so
or you dig into my penalties that I can
only play with my two back men and
nothing else
oh great okay okay I gonna only play
from back here so we're doing crisscross
yeah they're good and then her she's you
only got Wow okay so we've got this yeah
all right so now I have to score from
all the way back here in Colombia you'd
be dead now I probably would be I'd be
decapitated that's what they did with
the Colombian soccer player oh nothing
these guys good shot make your point
take your point oh that's right that
feels good it makes all the the first
game worth it you know yeah oh five will
they come back will they score will she
score yes oh oh wait I can't play with
that okay so no you can just pick it up
and put it where you want oh yes okay
okay it's calling Brandi yeah stops my
heart oh that was me okay so you are
sorry you can put it on your Phi bar you
can put on your three bar where you want
wherever you want to put it if you want
to spice it up Brett I don't give myself
a penalty shot you mind okay go for it
right I can do that
yep and let you do it you can move it
back to wherever you want it I hate not
being play okay
oh there you go sorry baby toe tap
so goofball is soccer more less yeah
table soccer yeah yes
so I played soccer
up until sixth grade and then moved to
football but in the fifth grade I scored
on my own team and a playoff game
oh my god are you still like traumatized
from that oh it was awful only only
because my buddy's dad on the drive home
was like silent cuz that going up being
how we lost and it was dead silent and
we're listening to Hootie the Blowfish
and and then he just the dead sound and
then he just go [ __ ] of Hootie it is
what is cuz what the [ __ ] were you
thinking
super-competitive Jesus that is [ __ ]
up drama time did you get some therapy
for that ok so I wanted to know what
also asked do you still do laser tag
like do you know they're like
competitions for that there are I don't
really have enough time to do it and
right and more boy
you do that every point so close
[Applause]
now we're gonna play a third round
called two ball when you guys lose the
penalty for losing is that you guys can
either do like pyramid push-ups five
pyramid pushes for Adam you're on the
bottom and a push-up formation and
Brad's on top of you and you guys have
to go down and up together five times or
you can both eat a dog treat Diddy so
you can call your parents and tell them
you're both being held captive on a hot
air balloon prop stuff wait so what's
the second option or I'm an adult like
get in the car and leave or you can eat
an oppa what brand of dog cheese yeah my
sister made me eat a dog bone when I was
six so you have experience so he's got
it yeah okay okay and what happens when
we win that we don't even bother what
happens when we win are we getting like
a dog treat enema for you or like what's
happening oh my god yeah oh god you're
gonna be a father someday now this is on
the Internet okay how about if that
happens we'll get to that but I really
don't think it will happen okay well how
I mean so we've never proposed any sort
of no and honestly since I've already
beat you guys both games I just feel
like we're all like wasting our lives we
all wasting our lives yeah there's a two
ball how about you have to live in that
motor home yes that's so extreme for a
week for a week I mean that's really
fair for a night Oh
no no cellphone no Wi-Fi no nothing okay
deal one two three sorry just a game
just a game Ravan fun oh also I forgot
to say this you guys can spin in this
round if you want oh well we would have
gotten both points we should just we
should just have oh no no no no I see
what you're doing okay that's a little
verse psychology that's what I call you
honest men you can spin
one two three go house go game
recognizes game yeah we continue one two
three go your competitive juices come
out if I can hear you I want it I want
it bad I want this w on the show that's
crazy yeah I can still watch that's all
you're saying is this special bonus
episode one two three go no no just an
Apple box now okay alpha box is coming
out Apple box here comes a code here
comes here comes up down up down left
right left right a B a B slow start
that's what's happening right now oh
it's a whole new world
oh my - yes all right so now push-ups or
dog treats push-ups are dog treats
that's great yes Oh God I mean I could
give me the dog for ya if they're good
for dogs well that's never I no one's
ever said that are they is it half a
tree or the whole tree the whole tree
okay oh god I have a dog I give my dog
no bones
he's got allergies and these are like
are nothing they're they're they're just
like wheat they're like crushed wheat so
don't worry about yeah it's just like
crushed
yeah that's it yeah and also this is dog
food
could you just going wow the whole thing
what are you parched now sir good oh boy
it's got like a little little pukey this
is [ __ ] love this she's doomed the
ginger ale like it's a [ __ ] like it's
actually good
yeah oh [ __ ] man I will Oh God Oh Larry
with a homeless bubble why didn't you
guys just do some push-ups
- hi-yah I won't fall again no love oh
my god you guys are so committed I love
it we're doing we're doing both
punishments right there buddy can you do
a Heimlich let me get some chili or
something oh my god but no we're not
doing both punishments you recommended
mm-hmm
I should have done the push-ups is it
hidden you know yeah a little bit
do you want to know the ingredients of
what you're eating Oh pure point spear
week Oh God
absolutely don't say oh it's weak what's
in the dog line chew and swallow yeah Oh
God oh [ __ ]
okay that was a bad idea yeah what is
what is he so the first two ingredients
are whole wheat and wheat flour ah
however yeah the third ingredient yeah
meat and bone meal Oh what kind of bones
not specify all right they just put
bones why aren't dogs requiring more out
of their diet yeah no kidding hey give
us a bone well I mean you guys did
essentially take like a multivitamin by
eating them there's not the vitamin on
there
I've been eating Flintstones for years
that was not even close to a cherry Fred
yeah where can people find you guys plug
your stuff up you can outside yeah
that's where we're gonna find us you
find me and an adoption agency hopefully
some nice Danish couple picks me up now
is it more expensive to adopt a dwarf
than it is a baby it's got to be under
the table right
it's the about last night podcast which
is on iTunes and then my Twitter is at
funny bread my Instagram is at Brad
Williams comic problems Comi calm has
all my tour dates awesome we're gonna
find you Adam you can see me my
communication game with Twitter and -
like podcast my album is out called read
the room and get river audio is is found
I can hear you chewing it it sounds like
you Tom Brown smells bad you guys can
follow me on instagram at Kelsey cook
comedy my website is Kelsey cook calm
and make sure to subscribe to Olympics
comedy and that I'm specifically
oh my god
[Music]
let this happened oh I think times I was
doing it to offer help
that's the dwarf call for help there
should be more dwarves arriving very
shortly did you smoke thank you guys for
watching another episode of risk fury be
sure to pick up your official Larisa
fury shirts that they are buttery soft
they feel like dolphin skin they're
lovely
be sure to LIKE and subscribe to the all
things comedy channel and you can get
the shirts at the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you